[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir à tous bienvenue pour cette
nouvelle demi heure d'information locale
voici les titres de ce mercredi 4
juillet l'objectif olympique n'est que
dans six ans mais il se prépare déjà à
accueillir l'événement planétaire les
entreprises et collectivités planche en
ce moment sur les jeux olympiques de
2024 le territoire de saint quentin en
yvelines mobilise notamment les acteurs
pour réfléchir aux problématiques de
déplacement ou de sécurité une matinée
d'échangés était organisée aujourd'hui à
l'estaca de en juillet et 3 en août au
total cinq policiers étrangers vont
passer leur été à versailles en échange
est inscrit dans le cadre de l'opération
commissariat européen depuis dix ans et
qui permet de créer des liens entre les
services de sécurité mais aussi et
surtout de faciliter la communication
avec les touristes étrangers les
touristes et visiteurs ils seront
d'ailleurs nombreux cet été sur l'île de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines ils
pourront profiter de nombreuses
animations théâtrales ou du cinéma en
plein air le point sur les animations
estivales avec vincent couteau
responsable événementiel du site et puis
invités de ce journal également de
membres du comité départemental de
france parkinson nous évoquerons avec
eux les différents ateliers proposés aux
proches aidants des malades
c'est donc dans six ans que paris
recevra les jeux olympiques d'été des
jo-2020 4 qui se dérouleront également à
saint quentin en yvelines ou six
épreuves sont programmées
un événement qui se prépare dès
aujourd'hui ce matin les pôles de
compétitivité movéo et systematic
paris-region organisé une matinée
dédiée sur le campus de l'estac à
montigny le bretonneux un rendez vous
pour faire émerger des projets et
compétences pour l'organisation de la
plus grande compétition sportive au
monde précision et reportage de grégory
karnas les écarts la vie gens comment
permettre un accès facile aux épreuves
alerté gérer une situation de crise
quelle diffusion de l'information
autant de questions auxquelles il faudra
répondre d'ici les jeux olympiques et
paralympiques à paris en 2024 cette
matinée dédiée à l'estaca à montigny le
bretonneux avait pour but de poser les
jalons des projets en matière de
mobilité de sécurité et d'information
dans la salle des entreprises et acteurs
des pôles de compétitivité movéo et
systematic paris-region les jo de 2024
seront une opportunité extraordinaire et
seront une deadline aussi qui va pousser
les entreprises à se fédérer pour
proposer des solutions assez innovante
des technologies qui peuvent aider à la
sécurisation des sites à la facilitation
de la mobilité des transports pour les
visiteurs mais aussi pour les sportifs
fluidifier la circulation de
des 15 à 20 millions de visiteurs
attendus à l'occasion des jo sur le
territoire en 2024 et quatre sites à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines accueilleront
six épreuves des jo l'événement fera
venir au total 15 à 20 millions de
visiteurs à paris et sa banlieue
et dès aujourd'hui donc il faut
recueillir les projets innovants et
penser la logistique on a un petit peu
de temps mais pas tant que ça c'est déjà
dans six ans et l'intérêt de pouvoir
faire émerger des idées sur saint
quentin en yvelines d'entreprise de
saint quentin en yvelines en tout cas du
plateau de sacrée en général au pouvoir
répondre à des besoins liés à
l'organisation pour optimiser
l'organisation des jeux assure saint
quentin en yvelines le territoire pourra
déjà se tester en septembre avec la
ryder cup
soixante mille personnes par jour
devrait venir au golf national de saint
quentin en yvelines lors des jo en 2024
est la seule épreuve de golf devrait
attirer 30000 spectateurs
quotidiennement dans l'agglomération il
dénonce une fermeture beaucoup trop
longue et s'inquiètent aussi pour
l'avenir de la piscine de maurepas le
collectif citoyen à une piscine pour
tous s'est réuni hier devant le centre
nautique fermé depuis trois ans
maintenant
il réclame notamment une meilleure prise
en compte de leurs attentes alors que la
gestion de l'établissement intercommunal
a été confiée à un gestionnaire privé
réaction au micro de michael et demi
d'euros la piscine c'est d'abord un
service public alors l'émission service
public c'est d'abord que la priorité
soit donnée à l'apprentissage de la
natation pour les scolaires donc que les
scolaires puis se retrouver l'accès à la
piscine ce qui n'est plus le cas depuis
trois ans après on avait dans la piscine
de des clubs sportifs des associations
de loisirs
très important il y avait en particulier
le club des nageurs de saint quentin qui
représentait 900 adhérents le club de
plongée qui était un très gros club
également
donc ces clubs doivent
absolument retrouver leur place dans
cette piscine et pour être complet sur
le sujet sachez que les trois communes
concernées elancourt morte pas et
coignières viennent de lancer une
concertation publique
les habitants sont invités à répondre à
un sondage sur les sites internet des
mairies jusqu'au 27 septembre
il ne parle pas français mais italiens
espagnols de policiers étrangers ont
rejoint en début de semaine le
commissariat de versailles présent pour
l'été les agents ont pour mission de
faciliter la communication avec les
nombreux touristes étrangers qui
viennent visiter la cité royale michael
et demi d'euros et car la vie gens ont
suivi une patrouille très européenne aux
abords du château
reportage depuis ce lundi 2 juillet de
nouveaux visages ont intégré
provisoirement les rangs de la police de
versailles morillo maturi de rome et
georges montésinos de valladolid vont
sillonner la cité royale cet été ils
sont parmi nous parce qu'il existe un
dispositif de coopération renforcée en
europe depuis 2008 qui consiste donc à
bénéficier de renforts de policiers
européens sur les sites qui sont
particulièrement touristique ou qui
accueille un événement festif culturel
sportif
leur mission patrouille avec les
effectifs français autour du château de
versailles pendant la journée et de
policiers étrangers bilingue auront pour
principal objectif de venir en aide aux
touristes étrangers
comme sagan de nous voir
hillis a pu se rassurer et s'il arrive
quelque chose il vient de voir avec la
police c'est toujours un aidant plus
puisque puisque la langue espagnole et
on la voit clairement sur le sur le
parvis du château donc cesser c'est une
facilité pour la communication pour tous
types de de gestion cet été deux autres
gardiens de la paix venus de l'étranger
viendront garnir les effectifs
versailles et au mode août un agent
espagnole et une policière allemande
ils sont plus de 8 millions en france à
soutenir leurs proches atteints d'une
maladie ou de vieillissement parfois
oubliés des politiques publiques et de
la société
on évoque là bien sûr ceux que l'on
surnomme les aidants et c'est pour les
aider à leur tour libérer leur parole
souffrances et les sortir de l'isolément
que le comité yvelines de l'association
france parkinson organise des groupes de
parole et ateliers de sophrologie
al marri brigue ou et philip glass
called bonsoir à tous les deux si vous
êtes respectivement membres et
responsable du comité local de
l'association
est-ce que vous pouvez déjà nous
expliquait mari brigue ou en quoi
consistent ces moments de ces groupes de
paroles qui sont organisés mensuellement
du côté de fourqueux oui absolument
écouter ces groupes existe donc depuis
seulement quatre mois
on est venu là parce que j'ai été invité
par une psychologue à paris
où elle organiser des groupes d dont
justement des groupes de paroles pour
aidants donc je me suis dit ça serait
une très bonne chose sur les yvelines
vous avez senti un besoin besoin
vraiment véritable besoin
moi j'ai un conjoint qui a la maladie de
parkinson donc déjà personnel et ensuite
je me suis dit mince ça pourrait servir
à beaucoup de personnes
voilà intéressés en tout cas vous aussi
vous aussi vous aviez senti ce besoin
avec avec ses cours de sophrologie enfin
je ne sais pas si on peut dire cours
mais c'est des ateliers de sophrologie
dons qui sont qui sont tenus par
infection animé par une par une par du
sophrologue
alors c'est ça c'est ça s'est mis en
place il ya à peu près deux ans
maintenant donc avec l'intérêt en fait
de la sophrologie c'est des méthodes qui
sont basés sur ceux de leurs de la
relaxation et qui permet en fait de
prendre conscience de son corps de ses
douleurs disent qu'il est dépassé 1 du
stress mais le stress qui accompagne en
fait les dents par rapport à la maladie
alors là facile à utiliser puis qu'on
entend par et dont c'est pas forcément
clair pour tous mais ce sont les
personnes qui sont par professionnelle
et qui aident tous les jours lors leurs
proches leurs conjoints dans la maladie
dans l'accompagnement la maladie tout à
fait tout à fait vous avez raison tout à
fait vous quels sont les besoins
principaux camps les gens viennent vous
voir que ce soit pour la sophrologie que
ce soit pour le groupe de parole qu est
ce qui ressort de tout ça principalement
ggd alors surtout en fait au delà de ça
on saurait ni aussi une fois une fois
par mois enfin dans les différentes
antennes du du comité puisqu'il ya trois
antennes
il ya trois antennes sur le département
assure sur versailles sur four que saint
germain et puis sur le bus clémente a
jolly et est ce qu'on les gens ce qu'ils
viennent chercher surtout un cessez de
l'information avant tout c'est du
soutien
savoir ce qu'est ce qu'il va se passer
beaucoup de questionnements
beaucoup de craintes 1 essayez dossier
de dos rond plus seulement dans lequel
sont venus partager des moments avec des
personnages et des mouvements travers
exactement s'ils sont union des
questionnements par rapport aux sondés
s'ils sont bien suivis aussi on peut
leur donner des conseils
alors on n'est pas évidemment des
médecins on est simplement des gens qui
ont une certaine expérience de la
maladie dont on peut partager un certain
nombre de choses avec eux sur et aussi
de rassurer bien sûr on est là présente
c'est obligatoire d'avoir une
psychologue à côté de vous il ya des ya
des séquelles psychologiques
en tout cas c'est plus intéressant tout
de même parce qu'elle peut si vous
voulez maîtriser un peu la parole faire
attention à ce que les uns parlent eux
un peu moins que d'autres ou peluches et
enfin et c'est donc ça c'est très
important oui oui je crois que c'était
il ya des thèmes après sur chaque à
chaque groupe de parole en fait il ya un
thème qui devrait qui vaille qu'il a
émergé sont pour le thème de le prochain
thème pour avoir une idée des thèmes qui
sont évoqués ou le thème path est ce que
vous avez ce souvenir là peut-être pas
non non tu as vraiment parce que nous ne
commençons seulement entre nous et
justice mis en place tout à fait à
versailles aussi ccc mensuel les à tenir
de sociologie ces deux fois par ses deux
fois par mois
or ce qui est important dire c'est que
aussi bien le groupe de parole que
l'atelier de sophrologie est pris en
charge à 100% par l'association grâce à
un grâce au programme
au programme d'entr'aide entrer dans un
qui est financé par l'irsn qui est un
institut de prévoyance
alors je me suis complètement gratuit
pour les peaux pour les adhérents de
france parkinson
il nous reste déjà très peu de temps
mais j'ai vu qu'à la rentrée y avoir
aussi des nouveautés pour les aidants
ceux qui sont au sein de l'association
un groupe de marche
si oui c'est exact mais pas uniquement
pour les aidons well as nous sommes
mélanger voilà c'est très particulier
pour les aidants voyez pas ce que je lis
je voudrais juste dire quelque chose de
didier robillard a écrit c'est le
président de notre association
il a écrit les dons doit apprendre à
comprendre à écouter agir avec un
conjoint aux réactions parfois
déroutante
voyez en espérant des situations c'est
difficile d'être aidé en voilà mais là
on est regroupée on est ensemble on
s'écoute et c'est très très chouette
et puis on peut avoir toutes les
informations que ce soit pour assister
au groupe de parole aux ateliers de
sophrologie sur le site national france
parkinson point fr et là on peut cliquer
sur le comité local d yves lignon
peuvent vous contacter c'est important
pour ceux qui s'occupent je crois que je
disais 8 millions de personnes qui
s'occupent des personnes atteintes de
maladies en france 200 milles
parkinsoniens en france donc si on fait
le ratio par rapport au département des
yvelines à peu près 4000 4000 par keynes
qui peuvent se tourner vers vous pour
avoir du soutien merci à tous les deux
d'être venu sur le plateau et on
rappelle l'adresse france parkinson
point fr merci les bibliothèques
universitaires de versailles de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines reconnu aux
normes le label marianne leur a été
remis le 29 juin dernier par l'afnor
l'organisme français chargé de vérifier
la conformité aux normes cette
certification de trois ans récompense la
qualité de l'accueil et des services
rendus par ces deux établissements
grégory canale pour les réactions
le label marianne et donc la propriété
de l'état c'est la déité paie
aujourd'hui qui
qui les détient donc c'est la direction
interministérielle de la transformation
public donc il comporte 12 engagements
disent qu'ils sont liés à l'accueil du
public des publics et de au management
des agents ça reconnaît quand même la
qualité des services proposés par les
par les bibliothèques universitaires de
saint quentin et de versailles puisque
ce sont les deux bibliothèques
universitaires qui reçoivent ce label
c'est aussi un soulagement parce que
c'est le résultat du travail de
plusieurs années
son nom ne vous dit peut-être encore
rien il vient d'être élu président du
medef le prouvent principal syndicat des
patrons vous voyez son visage geoffroy
roux de bézieux a été élu hier avec 55%
des voix à la tête du syndicat il a pu
notamment compter sur le soutien du
président du medef des yvelines bertrand
de créer celui ci a notamment apprécié
le rapport au terrain du nouvel élu
déclaration faite ce jeudi matin dans
l'émission paf diffusée sur tv 78 moi je
crois et parce que c'est une conviction
une conviction qu'il faut que le medef
d'être plus proche de son terrain plus
proche de ses territoires et geoffroy et
son équipe pour - incarne mieux ses
valeurs le fait que le rallye mort de
martin avec le sachet et pia orageux qui
a incarné ces votes être un symptôme
ralliait roux de bézieux a été
déterminant dans notre choix
on referme cette page économie avec un
résumé de l'actualité écho de ces quinze
derniers jours avec des locaux flambant
neufs pour que ligan france l'une
libération d'un fab lab à l'estaca ou
encore la générosité est d'un patron de
poissy aurélie ronge une nouvelle fois
pour ce résumé un lieu entièrement dédié
à l'innovation et à la réalisation de
projets bienvenue aux fab lab
ce laboratoire de fabrication numérique
intégré au sein de l'école d'ingénieurs
de l'estac à montigny le bretonneux
vient d'être inauguré ouvert depuis un
peu plus d'un an il met à disposition
des étudiants toutes sortes d'outils
comme des imprimantes 3d ou encore une
fraiseuse numérique
un vrai plus pour les étudiants
ingénieurs qui peuvent encore plus
imaginer et fabriquer les mobilité de
demain salle de repos cosy open space
lumineux la société culligan france dont
le siège social est à voisins le
bretonneux vient de moderniser ses
locaux leader mondial du traitement de
l'eau depuis plus de 80 ans être avant
c'était avant tout orientée vers le
bien-être des 80 collaborateurs
nous pensons qu'aujourd'hui le bien-être
des collaborateurs est une préoccupation
majeure pour les employeurs et que c'est
aussi un outil d'attraction des nouveaux
talents qui vont rejoindre culligan dans
les mois et années à venir
on a maintenant un très bel espace
détente qui permet de réunir l'ensemble
des collaborateurs de culligan france on
a également développé des concepts des
spas stand espace de coworking
nous avons des salles beaucoup plus
informel qui s'adapte à tous les types
et formats de réunions entre
collaborateurs
ce n'est pas la période de noël
et pourtant les 600 salariés de
l'entreprise yvelinoise nva pas et à
poissy viennent de recevoir 40 actions
gratuites
un joli cadeau d'une valeur de 2000 760
euros
anciennement environnement s à la
société dont le chiffre d'affaires
dépassé les 80 millions d'euros en 2017
et vient de fêter ses 40 ans et a donc
souhaité partager sa bonne santé
financière avec ses employés un exemple
à suivre
[Musique]
il fait beau il fait chaud vous l'avez
sûrement vu et senti c'est le début
aussi des grandes vacances l'occasion
évidemment de partir pour beaucoup
d'entre vous ou ou deux profiter si vous
restez à saint-quentin-en-yvelines des
sites touristiques locaux parmi eux
évidemment la traditionnelle il de
loisirs de saint quentin en yvelines
vincent couteau au bon soir vous êtes le
responsable communication événementielle
de lille le programme et est logiquement
est au fait c'est une
addition c'est aussi pour chaque été et
ses vacances pour les enfants
particularité pour ce mois de juillet et
ce mois d'août c'est assez étonnant la
présence de plusieurs activités autour
du théâtre on s'est un peu étonnant pour
une île de loisir d'avoir des activités
théâtrales cet animé par la compagnie
les tréteaux de france est-ce que vous
pouvez nous en dire plus sur ces
justement animations théâtrales oui tout
à fait on est très très heureux de les
accueillir c'est un vrai beau projet les
autres taux de france est une compagnie
nationale qui va venir vraiment
s'installer chez nous pendant l'été avec
plusieurs éléments d'abord des ateliers
sur les week-ends on va y revenir et
ensuite un chapiteau donc la wii vont
déplacer le théâtre sur l'île de loisirs
donc oui si le tfc qui vient à l'île de
loisir complet ça permet quoi de toucher
un nouveau public ça permet aussi de
passer un moment original à lille de
loisirs voyez un peu de tout ça c'est
quelque part le théâtre c'est aussi un
loisir l'aurait la culture et loisirs ne
s'oppose pas forcément et donc c'est
vraiment amener le
théâtre effectivement aux portes de ce
qu'ils n'y pensent pas forcément en
vacances ça sera entièrement gratuit
bref tout le monde donc ça aussi on n'a
pas forcément l'occasion d'aller là on
précise tout de suite qu'il faut
réserver parce que c'est sur inscription
et qu'il risque d'y avoir peu importe
les ateliers où les spectacles beaucoup
de monde
exactement donc il ya un numéro de
téléphone ou un site internet qui me
ferait vraiment russe à tout le monde de
s'inscrire et vaut mieux privilégier de
l'inscription que ça permet d'être
assuré d'avoir une place et ses
activités ses premières activités
débutent le samedi 14 juillet dans une
dizaine de jours où il sera question
notamment de jeu masqué du lecture à vos
de danses traditionnelles des ateliers
vous l'avez dit ouvert à tous initiés ou
débutants c'est très varié ça s'adresse
à tout le monde
ça s'adresse vraiment à tout le monde ce
sont des comédiens professionnels qui
vont animer ces ateliers qui ont
l'habitude de travailler aussi bien avec
des débutants des gens qui viennent pour
la première fois dire je voudrais mettre
au théâtre où je voudrais juste essayer
cas des gens qui sont déjà à l'aise qui
en font déjà toute l'année et lors le
club ferme peut être justement enfin je
compte donc c'est vraiment ouvert à tous
l'occasion les accuse si on est un peu
timide et qu'on n'ose pas se lancer dans
une troupe durant l'année classique j'ai
envie de dire c'est l'occasion peut-être
de commencer le théâtre dans un décor
particulier exactement que vraiment ils
ont essayé de balayer toutes les toutes
les qualités qu'on peut retrouver dans
le théâtre
ça va être aussi bien des jeux avec le
corps que juste des jeux de diction
juste de l'argumentation enfin c'est
vraiment très très ludique très sympa et
ça doit vraiment pas faire peur du tout
cas c'est vraiment accessible à tous
alors pour conclure sur cette partie
théâtre les spectacles eux seront donnés
en revanche au mois d'août avec une
semaine vraiment temps forts si j'ai
bien noté ce entre le 10 et le 14 août
c'est ça exactement
est-ce que vous pouvez nous en parler il
y aura un chapiteau vous le disions en
introduction
voilà donc un chapiteau sur la pointe
sud de l'étang plutôt près de la porte
du parc pour ceux qui connaissent bien
l'île des loisirs et concrètement on
aura tous les jours des représentations
mais là aussi avec des comédiens
professionnels avec des décors avec des
costumes on pourrait peut-être croire
instinctivement sdi du théâtre à lille
de loisirs
du théâtre un peu bas de gamme men ont
assez des vrais professionnels c'est des
vrais spectacles il ya un vrai intérêt à
aller le voir
tout à fait c'est des communes à qui se
produisent dans des grandes salles un
peu partout au moins en france et donc
vraiment là c'est dans le chapiteau des
beaux spectacles et dans la journée on a
aussi des petits spectacles itinérants y
en a qui qui qui m'amuse beaucoup
c'est dans un confessionnal avec un
comédien qui va lire de la poésie
pendant trois minutes
donc on attend son attend son tour pour
passer écoutez trois minutes de poésie
et repartir donc c'est vraiment voilà en
plein coeur de l'été ça fera toujours du
bien trois minutes de poésie quand ce
n'est pas le théâtre ça sera le septième
art qui s'invite sur sur l'île avec des
séances en plein air fin juillet oui 25
et 26 juillet donc le 25 avec le film
passion de sur la vie de grand corps
malade vraiment très sympa et le 26 à
laquelle chocolat est resté en local
omar sy voilà donc deux séances de
cinéma qui vont se dérouler au sein de
sky parc donc l'ancienne piscine à
vagues et donc il y aura aussi de la
restauration c'est là aussi ça va être
particulier une séance de cinéma ligne
de loisirs dans cette verdure dont c'est
dans ce décor basque et je ne sais qu'en
fait c'est sait on est au coeur de saint
quentin en yvelines mais on est vraiment
en pleine nature donc pas une seule
lumière vient perturber la séance
voilà un beau ciel étoilé je l'espère
ces jours là l'entrée sera gratuite
exceptionnellement partir de 19 heures
pour assister à ces séances a donc voilà
donc de belles sa hausse il faudra se
presser j'imagine un mot sur une
respectons mais sur les activités je
vais dire un peu plus classique
notamment pour pour ceux qui aiment les
sensations fortes le benji
éjection vent voir des images c'est
assez impressionnant là ça s'adresse à
qui sait ce qui est justement les
sensations uniquement alors non ce qui
est cassé mans c'est qu'aujourd'hui
encore quelqu'un qui avait le vertige et
ne voulait pas aller sur les parcours a
bien voulu s'essayer au benji éjection
et pour le coup à trouver d'autres sans
cesse les images l'instant voilà on
règle les élastiques de façon fait un
premier saut plus tranquille et un
deuxième saut où on peut voir bastien
salariés l'île de loisirs dans le quai à
ces fanas du bng éjection de classe est
reversé niveau maximum c'est pas
toujours comme ça non ça peut être plus
plus simple mais ce qui est sympa c'est
qu'en plus on en a une vue magnifique
sur les temps donc c'est et c'est
uniquement sur cette saison là d'accord
c'est une nouveauté qui restera qu'un
envoi la dernière nouveauté on terminera
là dessus du côté du ski parle aussi du
airsoft sur un parcours en gros on est
on se met dans la peau d'un soldat en
clair d'un militaire oui voilà mais de
façon très très très ludique est là
encore est très très légère mais le
principe c'est on a un petit parcours
chronométré et on doit un à plusieurs
postes de tir et on tire sur sur des
casseroles sur des objets etc
il faut faire le parcours le plus
rapidement possible et ça vient
s'ajouter aux activités de skype heures
qui sont le pilotage de drones les
trottinettes électriques sur un petit
circuit le golfe les bills sur l'eau etc
et puis il ya toutes les autres
activités habituelles la ferme
pédagogique le golf l'équitation
impossible de s'ennuyer cet été à lille
de loisirs on peut aller sur le sur le
site intéresse c'est habituel tous les
détails sur le site internet merci
vincent couteau d'être venu en plateau
et du coup très bel été à vous merci de
la culture pour refermer ce journal noël
n'est que dans six mois mais il est déjà
dans la tête dans d'ivoire la fédération
de chorales enregistre actuellement un
cd de 12 titres avec des choeurs
d'enfants du conservatoire de limay
celui ci servira à financer leur
festival festivoix un festival est dédié
aux personnes en situation de handicap
nicolas landry a assisté à l'une de ces
répétitions reportage
[Musique]
ils donnent leur voix pour andy voit la
fédération nationale mais dans les
yvelines
elle a été fondée par joël le toullec
c'est une fédération de chorales de
personnes handicapées ou en situation de
handicap tous handicaps confondus et
toutes générations confondues et on a un
réseau de chorales sur à peu près 30% du
pays quoi à peu près un peu plus donc on
ne cesse de se développer d'année en
année ces jeunes artistes viennent du
conservatoire de lui mais il interprète
des chants de noël des classiques et des
créations plusieurs jours de travail
avec une concentration très importante
déjà ce qui est important c'était leur
dire que c'était pour un enregistrement
parce que donc c'est pas la même chose
quand enfin d'enregistrement d'un
concert quand on a un public sont le
public en temps et puis ça passe par
contre quand on a un enregistrement
c'est pas le public qu'on a c'est les
micros et les micros sont intraitables
une vingtaine d'artistes participent à
la création de ce projet parmi eux le
clae siens georges schmit virtuose de la
flûte de pan j'ai le bonheur pendant
plus de trente ans de faire des concerts
spectacles jeune public soit l'appel et
ça m'arrive encore d'en faire un jeu là
vous et avec plaisir je vais à la
rencontre de ses enfants
voilà je fais découvrir la musique
classique la musique tous styles de
musique à travers la flûte de pan
le cd sera disponible pour les fêtes de
fin d'année 2010 8 enregistre nom
permettra de financer le festival
national de chorales festivoix c'est la
fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci de
l'avoir suivi vous pouvez retrouver
cette édition en replay sur tv et 78
points comme ou l'application tv 60,18
tout de suite vous retrouvez le 7-8
culture de mélanie poké belle soirée à
tous sur tv 78
[Musique]